c'est un séisme politique
pour la première fois
un sondage donne une majorité RN à l’Assemblée nationale
en cas de dissolution et d'élections législatives anticipées
le magazine L’Obs a révélé ce sondage secret
commandé par Les Républicains en décembre
pour « prendre le pouls du pays » selon l'entourage d’Éric Ciotti
énorme surprise
le Rassemblement national arriverait en tête du scrutin
et triplerait son nombre de sièges avec 278 députés
ce qui est tout proche de la majorité absolue
avec un tel score
Emmanuel Macron n'aurait d'autre choix
que de nommer un Premier ministre de cohabitation
Jordan Bardella a déjà fait savoir qu'il accepterait une telle responsabilité
la majorité s'effondrerait avec seulement 135 députés
contre 249 actuellement
autant dire que le président n'a aucun intérêt à dissoudre l'Assemblée
puisque ça serait une véritable boucherie pour sa majorité
la gauche serait également en recul avec 89 députés
et ce en partant du principe qu'il y ait des candidats Nupes
ce qui est loin d'être évident puisque l'alliance n'existe plus
enfin LR qui était à l'origine de ce sondage
enregistrerait une légère baisse en passant de 62 à 53 députés
« une stabilisation encourageante de nos scores »
selon l'entourage d’Éric Ciotti
en tout cas le RN est prêt à faire campagne en cas de dissolution
Jordan Bardella a déjà préparé un « plan Matignon »
pour mener une campagne éclair de quelques semaines
des candidats ont déjà été pré-investis
les circonscriptions et la logistique passées en revue
et Marine Le Pen a demandé à Jordan Bardella
de préparer son gouvernement
le président du RN commence vraiment à y croire
Le Point révélaitcette semaine
que Jordan Bardella avait demandé à Gabriel Attal
de visiter les appartements privésde Matignon